Darrin's ancient bazaars are the beating
heart of this city the coronavirus means
it's beating a little softer these days
with stay-at-home orders still in effect
the call to prayer comes from an empty
mosque the city's bread makers carry on
to make sure people have enough to eat a
work is easy we're comfortable we have
no problems but nobody brings us hand
sanitizer disinfectant or masks the
government brought nothing we have to
pay for it from our own pocket kovat 19
has done what for years economic
sanctions failed to bring Iran's economy
to a near standstill Iran's government
is looking to breathe life back into
businesses as soon as possible the grand
bazaar is the symbol of Iran's
mercantile tradition and it really is
strange to see this place so empty on
any given day it's bustling was people
buying and selling some of the people
who live in this neighborhood Iranians
that we've spoken to say that this
Bazaar an important indicator of the
health of the country's economy probably
hasn't been this empty in centuries Iran
is a land bridge connecting Europe Asia
and the Middle East
merchants trade has been a part of the
fabric of this country for millennia
if shops don't reopen soon Iranians
worry some may never be able to open
again
all these years that we have been doing
business here we've never seen such a
vast closure of the bazaar the reason is
this virus that showed up disease is
disease it's not up to me or you it
happens if I'm going to contract Khurana
today I'll get it if I don't contract it
I want it is up to fate
the corona virus is still killing people
but a nationwide travel ban will be
lifted this month and shops will begin
to reopen this week the grand bazaar
with narrow alleyways full of people
would be the perfect place for a virus
to spread so most markets like this will
remain closed for now President Hassan
rouhani has said people can begin to
return to work safely the head of Tehran
city council disagrees we are concerned
about another outbreak in Tehran we
expect the National counter Korona task
force to use the city's councils
experience to make more realistic
decisions traffic jams are already a
common sight once again health experts
have warned relaxing control measures
that took weeks to implement risks a
second outbreak but whatever the numbers
whatever the warnings whatever the risk
to save Iran's economy the government
says roads and shops must reopen and
whether people like it or not it is
already happening same bus Ravi
al-jazeera DEKRA